[Music]
you recently did comedy for a very
difficult audience is that right yeah I
had the craziest gig ever I do a lot of
a corporate stand-up comedy and I got to
roast the NFL owners before the Super
Bowl
and it was just them it wasn't you did
the big gig I did a show called the NFL
honors and yeah it's not it's like it's
a room full of a lot of the athletes and
a lot of people in sports I had none of
the athletes just the billionaires
that's the time that's billions they've
experienced all joy they don't drive
they don't like what do you talk to them
about I'm like hey don't you hate when
you're cooking pilot or in cahoots yeah
I actually got heckled by Jerry Jones
Jerry Jones
yeah the Cowboys how is he I said Jerry
Jones is here tonight and he just said
don't do it
these guys are so used to getting what
they want yeah don't even think about it
buddy don't do it
yeah Jerry I'm gonna do it yeah I said
one I said Jerry of course you know that
Jerry made his money in the oil business
it's nice to know somebody in your
organization can run a successful
two-minute drill how do you like that
I'm just glad I'm not dead it's not
killed me yeah go after any players at
all or anything
I know players it was like it was 20
billionaires and it was tough but you
know it came up to me afterwards so this
guy from the Chargers walked up and he
goes that was hilarious but you realize
none of us could laugh right oh that's
great ah then one of the Bears grandkids
came up and she goes I just wanted to
know I loved it but did you know it was
an impossible gig when you took it bans
now why are they gonna hire him work of
me yeah who else is on the show but that
was the lineup it was Jeremy Renner me
and the Steve Miller Band that is so
random that's a random collection that's
so yeah and right before I walked up I
was sitting next to the CEO of Pepsi she
looks at me and Jeremy Renner's on stage
and she said who is he and why is he
talking yeah what was he do what does
jeremy renner do in that situation
he has a couple pops just just is Jeremy
Renner's yeah I am Jeremy Renner exact
know a group like that you can't you
can't reference anything from real life
because now yeah I've been in front of
groups like that and you and you say
things like yeah you know you know when
you're going to get your baggage at the
airport just silence yeah yeah they
don't know what the hell you're talking
about
nope they're like there's no baggage
it's all handled
[Laughter]
you know Paul Paul Allen the owner of
like everything in Seattle he couldn't
be there because his yacht crashed into
a protected coral reef don't you hate
when that happens
[Laughter]
you